you're gonna do to me what are you gonna
do to me when you find me
[ __ ] a cat alright alright alright
alright okay okay okay okay okay I'll do
it you're gonna do already shut up I'm
lady no care what the old man did I care
what you do right now huh no cuz it all
doesn't import oh god I'm so dead
well I was right about one thing I was
dead oh this is your last chance to turn
back okay
yeah disturbing for search for anomalies
sexual
these are sexual anomalies funny
debatable I will sir move a to blue
skills ok bye spider leave now
I'm nearly there they're nearly up my
butt they are trying to stop me in my
patootie
oh hello I don't know what I was trying
to do there can I go beer good yeah
Oh dick with me ah [ __ ]
let's you lose Giulio died I picked up a
piece of paper and you tell me to die
isn't that a little extreme here oh wow
oh the sounds are like Oh God what the
[ __ ] he's gonna kill they oh god he's
gonna kill a new you I hate that sound
there we go
God ha ha what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
dining dis nah Froy dick hi it's not a
person
oh I just titles apartheid oh good lordy
like a frog yeah you silly [ __ ] I need
to get my revenge for poisoning myself
by grabbing on to the tooth of a what
was that ha ha what up [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh god some L was that I'm sort of
crystal everybody's seen a disembodied
head here just randomly strewn about
sitting down
maybe they run run you douche [ __ ]
goddammit my fines well this was a fun
room in here
lots of oh hi hi how's it going
we're good to see ya hug the neighbors
not the family how's the kids what are
you doing I can't look away
Thanks
huh have a good one I think I'll pass on
this one it's going bye-bye Barry oh hi
okay crematorium it's ryan right
I can't Crocky mini Christmas yeah even
more gross god hi haha
good God your smile is awesome today huh
no I'm out god dammit I was always out
come on let's come in right around the
corner or Givenchy Lee no oh oh oh he's
coming oh he's good
oh oh oh just don't hurt me go
um
hey thanks for watching all of the
videos in this compilation are available
in the description so check them out and
if you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today
or if you're already subscribed share
this video with a friend thanks again
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video bye bye